hello there my children it's me scp-343
but you probably know me better as god
it's been strange lately hasn't it to
the untrained eye it seems like things
are only getting crazier out there
nothing seems certain or safe anymore so
naturally you've got questions for me it
makes sense in your position i'd
probably do the same thing so let's see
what burning queries are on your mind
and of course i'll do my best to answer
them indigo wolf said i'd ask me for
instructions what's the best way to
raise
scp-999 to be ready for the scarlet king
so we'd be fully prepared for his
arrival ah the scarlet king he is a
nasty customer i try to avoid
associating with him when i can vibes
are atrocious and he certainly has some
unpleasant plans for everything i've
created if ever he gets his way but to
answer your question about how best to
raise scp-999
well to me the answer is obvious with
love the scarlet king is a master of
malice and savagery and therefore malice
and savagery cannot be used as tools
against him only the light of love can
burn out the hate hiding in the dark
tyron morgan oh hello tyron good to see
you you said i'd ask why does he choose
to be at an scp foundation site rather
than in the world helping people well
tyron there are many ways to help and
not all of them mean getting involved
directly a set of training wheels can
help someone ride a bike but they will
never truly know how to ride until the
training wheels are removed what's that
saying you all came up with the lord
helps those who helps themselves that i
do clockwork snowmen oh that is a fun
name said i would ask me something about
how i said it's not one of mine when
asked about 682 and then who did make it
well
there are certain details i'd rather not
get into when discussing that thing but
all i can tell you is whoever made it
didn't make it with love beasts like
that are perversions of the gift of
creation it doesn't even enjoy its own
life is that any way to exist we must
pity it if anything knocked 28 high said
i guess an interesting question would be
what do i think of atheists well that
depends on the atheist i've known
angelic atheists and monstrous believers
and of course vice versa what matters
most in life is that you are a good
person that you're kind and
understanding to your fellow human
beings and that you leave the world a
little better than you found it even if
you don't believe in me if you're a good
person i will believe in you chase crow
oh i do love your name chase you said
are there any regrets that i have in
terms of what my creation has become
regret it is an interesting word the
greek playwright agathon once said only
this is denied even to god the power to
make what has been done undone i regret
nothing of my past because that past is
beyond all of us for what it's worth i'm
proud of all of you and especially you
chase irish spartan studios ooh that has
a ring to it said i'd ask me when will
the surviving infinite ikea video come
out it already has my son you see
patience is a virtue max's intense
videos now do be careful max said is
there any way to terminate the immortal
lizard or at the very least make him not
want to kill every living thing well
interesting but i've gone on record
saying this before but that thing isn't
one of mine the scp foundation will have
to figure out that nasty piece of work
by themselves dr veronica said i'd ask
me what's the name of the scp doctor we
see in all these videos with black hair
a black beard and glasses he's the one
presenting anomalies to us more than
anybody else so he must be important oh
he's a charming fellow we hang out every
wednesday and watch episodes of rupaul's
drag race on netflix i won't share his
name out here out of respect for his
privacy but rest assured you're in good
hands with him he also has a wonderful
voice brandon caminari oh hello again
brandon thank you for showing up you
said considering the foundation's
tendencies and devotion to their cause
other than the times i felt a divine
duty to intervene have i ever tried to
convince the foundation to cure
something or someone offered to
completely destroy an item or even make
their work easier you know frankly that
isn't my place the problem with ultimate
power is that it means you can't really
choose sides to put my finger on the
scale could lead to catastrophic effects
and if i save one person or even a
handful of people that means i'd need to
save everyone all the time and if i'm
always saving everyone you no longer
have free will brandon mangolad what a
fun name said i would ask me is there
any meaning to all the suffering and
insanity we face every day do we matter
on the grand scheme of things or are we
just pebbles on a road my friend my
child's suffering has no inherent
meaning in fact nothing does but the
beauty of that is that you get to choose
your own meaning suffering can weaken or
strengthen you it only depends on the
lessons you choose to take from it and
of course you matter in fact you're made
of matter just like everything else the
meaning of that is up to you akinho said
i would ask me about the disease that
scp-049 is trying to cure the pestilence
he was always a neat freak that one i
can't say i know what he's obsessed with
but i can only hope that the scp
foundation someday cures him of his
germaphobia chrysia said as much as i'd
love to ask me about other scps or deep
existential questions i would rather
just chill peacefully with me while we
eat hamburgers chrysia that certainly
sounds like a pleasant afternoon to me
you should swing by again sometime and
we'll hang out especially if you buy the
hamburgers this time don't lie to me my
child i knew you had your wallet on you
speedy lurchic said i think my question
would be how can i still be so kind in
the face of the cruelty on this planet
how come i don't become bitter or
desperate or angry well my child
nobody's perfect not even me there are
certainly times that i do feel desperate
bitter and angry but what is important
to remember is that this doesn't have to
stop you from being kind in a cruel
world you can choose to either be a part
of the cruelty or be one of the brave
people standing against it don't feel
bad for being angry let it pass pick
yourself back up and carry on with a
smile can we oh kenneth good to see you
you said i would ask me if there is any
scp that i fear and or is unwilling to
approach for any particular reason well
there's no scp i wouldn't approach but
there are definitely some i don't like
having in my company have you seen that
slimy old man from cell 106
incredibly unpleasant fellow antonio
ricardo moncoda osorio hello there my
friend said can i have a big chocolate
bar that's the question i would ask
before probably thinking of something
existential well antonio that all
depends on your answer to my next
question what is your favorite kind of
chocolate you never told me after all
daniel flores said ever since i read
about me i've actually always wanted to
sit and play chess with me no better
practice than god well you know what
they say failure is the best teacher and
if you play chess with me you're sure to
receive it i don't go easy my son
certain words what an interesting name
said a simple question what is my
purpose just so i can rest easy with my
end destination known your purpose my
child is to use your enthusiasm and your
skills to make yourself happy and make
the world a better place how exactly you
do that is up to you kid good luck
christina jones oh it's been a while
hello said how can i live forever then i
would spend the rest of our day talking
about distant galaxies and theoretical
physics my child you don't want to live
forever life seems awfully short to
happy people because time flies when
you're having fun conversely you won't
find anything duller than eternity
however i'll definitely take you up on
that distant galaxies and theoretical
physics conversation lizzie les enten
said honestly i would just ask god why i
let the world go to hell i'm a christian
and i know god believes in free will and
letting the world do its own thing but
sometimes i really wonder why i would
let some of the bad things happen to
good people or happen in general well
liz it is a tragedy really the problem
of evil why do the goods suffer while
the bad prosper why does cruelty exist
why are some fortunate and others seem
doomed from birth evil is the dark
residue of free will the ability for one
to choose their path in life it hurts
and my heart aches for its victims but
without choice there would be no evil
and no good you'd cease to even be human
and i could never do that to you royal
frosty said i would ask me on a date
having the ultimate scp boyfriend oh
i'm flattered by the sentiment but i see
you all as my children so i'd hate to
make it weird el squishy said i want to
ask me simply if i'm doing okay so far
in life oh and ask if i have any good
recipes i bet i do you're doing just
fine and as long as you keep love in
your heart and do everything you do with
the goal of bettering this world for
yourself and others you'll continue to
do splendidly and yes i know many good
recipes i owe it to my voracious reading
of anthony bourdain's books me rest his
soul gilda said god why am i so deeply
miserable and unable to enjoy or do
anything of importance anymore gilda my
child you might have depression speak to
some friends and loved ones about this
and see a therapist if possible i love
you and you're not alone just keep going
and i believe in you murdoch said with
me being the all-powerful creator of the
universe yes i am i would of course ask
me what's the deal with airline food i
see you two have been watching seinfeld
however my child the altitude high
decibel level and still air of a plane
environment weaken your ability to
register salty and sweet tastes causing
food consumed on a plane to appear more
bland and flavorless than food consumed
while on the ground hope that clears it
up for you my child pyrotechie uh really
quickly please stop playing with matches
said i'd ask to be granted my powers for
a day just to see from my perspective
though i might be terminated after oh
there's a delightful jim carrey film
called bruce almighty about why this
desire isn't what it's cracked up to be
i can safely say that morgan freeman
also does a wonderful job representing
yours truly alexander berry said is my
fate already determined or am i able to
choose mine it is as determined as you
want it to be alexander if you give
yourself in and refuse to make your own
choices then your fate ceases to be
yours to control but if you choose and
fight for your choice then your fate is
all your own decade gaming said i would
tell me to give me infinite pizza well
that may be a waste of my divine powers
my child when scp-458 the never-ending
pizza box exists the gaming bear said i
would ask where you could find the best
hamburger oh yes this is a good one
there are plenty of decent places to get
a hamburger on this fine earth but
personally i'm a fan of either five guys
or in and out gamefellers said does
satan exist satan in the sense of a
being who exists to tempt the weaker
members of mankind to evil and
corruption let me tell you my child
those people don't need the help henry
galley said i have a question for god
why well first off i appreciate the
reference to filthy frank but i'm afraid
that's one you're going to need to
figure out yourself thank you for all
the questions they've given me a lot to
ponder take it from your creator life is
a lot more interesting when you're
curious so never let the world beat that
out of you little disclaimer from the
foundation here whether this particular
anomaly is actually god himself or
simply a very powerful reality warper
it's a distinction we're not fully
comfortable making perhaps taking his
words with a little pinch of salt may be
an order now go check out scp-096 look
at a picture of shy guy in space the shy
guy questions and theories and scp-049
what actually is the pestilence the
plague doctor questions and theories and
keep an eye on our community tab for
more chances to take part in a video
like this one